this is one of the last moments recorded
on a camera before the
attack hundreds of people were attending
a military graduation in
hes among them Syria's defense minister
Ali Abbas he left a few minutes before
armed drone struck this is obviously a
real coup for whoever's carried it out
because is at a military base it's
Cadets it's targeted and uh it's using
advanced
technology the Syrian military accused
what it calls armed terrorist
organizations supported by known
International
parties we attended the ceremony till
the end and then we went to greet our
relatives then it was that massive sound
I woke up
here as we Stood Beside my brother there
was a huge explosion people were around
us on the ground I don't know what
happened to my
brother a day before Syria State tv
quoted the Russian commander in Syria
warning of possible attacks on Russian
or Syrian
positions according to the deputy head
of the Russian Center for reconciliation
of Waring parties Vim kulit terrorists
are planning to carry out a series of
attacks on the locations of the Russian
military and the Syrian
government
immediately after the attack government
forces bombarded Rebel held it live in
northern Syria several people are
reported to have been killed and more
injured no one has claimed
responsibility for the attack in hums
and in a country locked in Conflict for
years that has left people speculating
who would want to have carried it out
aliim
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler